bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 26 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur à
l'actualité locale on pourrait de nos
invités mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction on commence tout de
suite avec les titres de cette édition
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
versailles yvelines se pencher
aujourd'hui sur le développement à
l'international des pme et des tpe le
département représente aujourd'hui 12 %
des exportations francilienne mais
seulement 2 % au niveau national la fête
du conte se poursuit à saint quentin en
yvelines
le programme et les enjeux du rendez
vous expliquer tout à l'heure avec un
pub en plateau cécile à ferhat faire à
tout responsable des médiathèques et
enfin la maison d'édition décinois
heureux du monde va publier 7 janvier un
an après les attaques contre charlie
hebdo un livre pour expliquer aux
enfants
l'horreur comment aborder cette question
avec les plus jeunes nous en parlerons
avec le directeur de rue du monde alain
serres invité également du journal et
pour commencer cette information tpe et
pme donc petites et moyennes entreprises
se sont retrouvés aujourd'hui à la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines pour échanger autour
du commerce à l'international
de nombreux experts des secteurs
d'europe et d'afrique étaient présents
pour répondre à leurs questions retour
sur cette cinquième édition avec fanny
bourdon
fait de l'international c'était le mot
d'ordre ce matin à la chambre de
commerce de versailles ou entreprises et
experts ont été changées sur
l'importance du développement à
l'international
l'international n'est pas je dirais un
domaine infranchissable que ce n'est pas
une question de taille d'entreprise il
faut avoir un bon produit il faut avoir
une vraie véritables capacités je dirais
à se déplacer aller sur ces marchés
quelquefois un peu particulier parce que
culturellement c'est pas toujours facile
et que l'international c'est de la
longue haleine il suffit pas de faire un
aller-retour ou deux allers retours
évidemment c'est dans la durée que l'on
à un retour sur l'investissement
cette année pour cette cinquième édition
l'accent a été mis sur l'afrique un
continent au fort développement
économique
l'afrique est en attente de partenaires
et d'investisseurs dans tous les
secteurs finalement de 2 2 lors de leur
économie
ils cherchent beaucoup à se diversifier
et à diversifier leur voile aux
ressources la prod de partenariat et
d'approvisionnement 15 pays européens et
africains étaient représentés les
entretiens individuels avec ses experts
du commerce ont permis aux entrepreneurs
yvelinois de s'informer sur le potentiel
et les opportunités de ces pays très
important parce que ça qu'est bon afin
que certains marchés
qui se développe donc il vaut mieux être
en avance et un potentiel de
développement pour l'entreprise dans les
pays du maghreb d'une façon générale et
donc voilà donc j'ai commencé par la
tunisie parce que la dame était et est
libre donc mais voilà mais
potentiellement il ya aussi le maroc et
l'algérie qui m'intéresse la
participation au forum a augmenté de 40%
cette année
ce regain d'intérêt pour l'export est
plutôt bon signe
c'est une source importante de
croissance des entreprises en 2014 les
yvelines ont représenté 12 % des
exportations francilienne est ce soir en
plateau avec nous deux invités pour
parler littérature est plutôt
littérature destinée aux enfants à 20
serbes ont soir bonsoir vous êtes le
fondateur et directeur de rue du monde à
voisins le bretonneux donc une maison
d'édition vous allez nous parler dans
quelques instants d'un livre j'atteste
ont publié par rue du monde dont le
texte a été largement diffusé après les
attentats de charlier 2 notamment auprès
des enfants et que vous publiez donc
enrichie sous une forme en régie le
enrichit le 7 janvier 2016 donc c'est
forcément une dimension encore plus
forte après les attentats du 13 novembre
dernier à paris nous y reviendrons dans
quelques instants également présente
avec nous cécile fera-t-on bonsoir
bonsoir alors je me suis trompé
d'ailleurs vous êtes responsable du
service jeunesse à la médiathèque du
canal la 15e édition de la fête du conte
a débuté samedi 21 novembre sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines elle va se prolonger jusqu'au 5
décembre
et vous êtes ici pour nous en parler
donc pendant la fête du conte c'est la
quinzième édition j'ai maintenant un
grand rendez vous attendu oui
effectivement on s'est rendu compte que
petit à petit on a vraiment finaliser
les gens et qui en fait c'est vraiment
un rendez vous qui a tendu donc
généralement dès que le programme paraît
tout de suite on a des demandes
voilà et les gens ont vraiment envie de
ça je pense que d'autant plus que la
programmation est tellement diversifiée
que finalement chacun peut aussi
retrouver quelque chose qui l'intéresse
et puis aussi les gens sont assez mobile
sur le territoire donc en fait selon ce
qui les intéresse ils vont d'une ville à
l'autre voilà ils peuvent prendre un peu
voilà selon selon les envies du moment
en fait
alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
la fête du conte 7 c'est l'essentiel de
la manifestation tourne donc autour des
compteurs comment vous les avez un petit
buzz choisi ce que vous faisiez alors en
fait il ya des compteurs on va là qu'on
apprécie déjà titre personnel et donc du
coup on a envie de faire venir
donc cela effectivement on les sollicite
d'abord après il ya aussi des compteurs
en fait qu'on apprécie et qu'on fait
revenir d'une année sur l'autre
il y en a une à plusieurs pour qui ça a
été cette est le cas on travaille
également avec des associations aussi de
conteurs locaux qui qui peuvent aussi
faire des interventions auprès du public
donc après c'est vraiment une fonction
d'affinités voilà deux thématiques on a
envie de développer du public qu'on vise
aussi parce qu'il ya des compteurs qui
sont aussi spécialisés plus pour les
tout petits
ou au contraire plus grand public est
généralement ils ont un panel assez
diversifiée qui permet de choisir aussi
le spectacle qui immature correspondre à
notre public ou à notre envie aussi
voilà à dire que vous avez à des têtes
des choses comment reconnaît-on un bon
conteur alors ça c'est pas évident comme
question ça à mon compteur je pense que
c'est avant tout celui qui sait qui sait
capter le public et peu importe lequel
j'ai envie de dire parce
qu'effectivement nous bibliothécaire à
notre niveau on fait des heures du conte
dans l'année voilà on touche souvent un
public qui est plus un public de petits
avec des moyens bon qui peuvent être des
tapis de lecture des kamishibaï donc des
petits moyens mais qui malgré tout
apporte un petit plus après je pense que
le compteur lui c'est quand même
vraiment un art de capter déjà sans
support livres sont super documents et
puis aussi d'arriver à garder
l'attention
moi j'ai toujours été émerveillé par les
conteurs qui finalement arrive à capter
tous les publics y compris voilà y
compris des ados qui sont pas forcément
règle des publics très captif au départ
ou voilà autant des petits que des
parents en fait et vous finalement on a
absolument envie d'aller au bout de
l'histoire du compte voilà alors cela
s'adresse à tous les âges même les buts
c'est ton qui ça veut déjà un peu lié
mais est-ce qu'ils sont amis conti par
les auteurs oui généralement ça marche
si justement
tombe sur le bon conteur le bon
spectacle au bon moment oui bien sûr il
n'y a pas de souci par rapport à ça et
généralement bas c'est même souvent
qu'ils ont quittée pas envie vraiment
partie en fait que ça vise un public
assez large et sans traiter les enfants
il ya aussi des choses pour les adultes
il ya des d'autres inédits proposés
comme des ateliers d'écriture et de
création pareil de kamishibaï c'est ça
oui il ya en fait on a donc on a cherché
effectivement toucher un large public et
donc d'initiative qui était différent
donc c'est pas uniquement des spectacles
ça peut aussi être sous forme d'ateliers
et en fait ces ateliers qui se passe en
amont de la fête du conte ont une
restitution à ce moment là aussi pour
justement une visibilité pour le grand
public pas uniquement pour les
participants c'est vraiment l'idée en
fait de montrer ce qui se passe sur le
territoire la richesse aussi qu'il peut
y avoir sur ce territoire là et donc
pour ça on travaille en fait avec des
intervenants donc soit compteur soit
effectivement auteurs illustrateurs
jeunesse par exemple
donc il ya eu notamment effectivement
deux initiatives en atelier d'écriture
avec des adultes et qui donne lieu à une
lecture
et puis il ya eu également un travail
avec des classes de maternelle avec
lesquels on a créé un kamishibaï j'ai en
fait qui est exposé à la médiathèque du
canal pendant toute la durée de la radio
mais chez dsk c'est pour ça qu'elle
connaît alors un kamishibaï à l'origine
ça vient d'asie le principe c'est qu'on
raconte une histoire dans un petit
théâtre en bois en fait est le principe
c'est des planches que qui sont les unes
après les autres d'un côté il ya les
images et le derrière il ya le texte
donc en fait le l'intervenant
bibliothécaire lit le texte et les
personnes qui sont en face on les images
en fait en même temps et on tourne en
fait on passe les planches les vignes
derrière les autres pour lire en fête
l'histoire l'a fait je compte voilà
c'est un événement quand même très
familial mais il y aussi les choses
spécifiquement pour les adultes
notamment une conférence sur la figure
du monstre au cinéma le 28 août la
figure de monstre au cinéma le 28
novembre à 15h30 à la médiathèque jean
ruthless oui effectivement c'est samedi
après midi
donc là c'est quelque chose qui est un
petit peu innovant donc pour cette année
donc effectivement ils ont vraiment
envie que ça fonctionne aussi eu ce qui
les intéressait c est effectivement
aussi de pouvoir organiser quelque chose
d'un petit peu différent vraiment à
destination d'un public adulte sous
forme de conférences également mais qui
soit quand même assez interactive et
puis voilà qui puisse correspondre aussi
un petit peu enfin un peu à tout le
monde en fait à tous les adultes qu'ils
soient pas non plus quelque chose de
trop compliqué donc effectivement je
pense ça peut être très intéressant
d'autant plus que certains intervenants
qui est quand même spécialisés aussi
dans le cinéma
donc effectivement je vous engage
vivement à y aller parce que je pense ça
peut être vraiment vraiment très
intéressant il ya des thèmes un peu
spécifique qui ont été choisis cette
année vous avez choisi en fonction de
quoi tant paravent voyage ça oui allant
non en fait c'est on a choisi cette
thématique là pourquoi au canal pas pas
forcément dans les autres médiathèques
des fours les autres médiathèques
résille et voilà la brésil lorient nous
on a choisi le voyage en fait pourquoi
parce que déjà c'est un thème assez
large qui nous permettait de finalement
de badauds rassemblés plein
d'initiatives différentes
et puis aussi parce que justement sur le
thème du conte c'est quelque chose qui
je trouve se rapprochent partie enfin se
raccrochent particulièrement à ça parce
que je trouve que le conte par
définition c'est quelque chose qui fait
voyager
ne serait-ce que voyager dans
l'imaginaire et qui en plus c'est une
richesse énorme d'autant plus pas que ça
se raccroche à a finalement des
traditions orales aussi donc des
histoires qui se racontent et ça peut
être la même histoire mais qui ont
comptés de manière très différente dans
différents pays
donc c'était tout ça en fait qui était
qui était intéressant pour nous la
diversité dont ceux qu'on pouvait offrir
autour de ce thème sans rien faire
passer des messages
c'est d'ailleurs aussi ben je trouve que
le conte c'est aussi pour ça je suis
très contente en fait d'être en plateau
avec alain serres parce que je trouve
que leur travail pour ça et aussi
vraiment superbe je trouve que le conte
c'est aussi un moyen tout va la faire
passer des valeurs parce que par ce
biais là il d'imaginaire de fiction
voilà on transmet des messages aussi
alors plus ou forcément sous la forme de
la morale comme dans une fable voilà mai
mais en tout cas c'est souvent mal assez
souvent des textes très fort et je
trouve que voilà c'est important aussi
aujourd'hui et je pense d'autant plus
dans le contexte actuel en fait
justement nous allons y venir alain
serres donc les cons vous en publié
également dans votre maison d'édition
donc voilà si vous êtes d'accord c'est
un moine va passer à des messages aux
enfants mais les comptes sont l'héritage
de l'humanité immatériel et
voilà c'est une belle transmission on va
voir les notaires pour penser aux
transmissions parfois mais il faut aller
voir les compteurs ils nous transmettent
des choses beaucoup plus importantes qui
sont effectivement des manières de vivre
ensemble et manière d'affronter la vie
de résoudre ces problèmes de projeter
des manières de grandir et de parler
aussi de la mort du sentiment amoureux
enfin de tout ce qui fait la vie et tout
cela effectivement à part les compteurs
dans les comtés dans les livres il n'y a
pas grand monde qui peut en discuter
avec les enfants alors oui à des
ateliers philosophiques dans les écoles
par exemple c'est un bon moment aussi
d'échanger son point de vue sur la vie
mais le conte est un moment privilégié
dès le plus jeune âge donc une vitamine
est importante dans la vie de l'enfant
vous êtes ici pour ne pas non pas d'un
compte mais d'un livre que vous allez
voir que vous publiez le 7 janvier 2016
qui s'appelle j'atteste alors c'est à la
base un texte court d'adélaide sifflets
habits poète marocain qui a notamment
été lauréat du prix goncourt de la
poésie en 2009
vous l'avez celui prend une dimension
donc encore plus forte alors que la
france a une nouvelle fois été victimes
d'attentats avec les événements du 13
novembre dernier à paris
je le rappelle ont fait 130 morts et 450
de blessés donc c'est un événement qui
est difficile à expliquer aux enfants
et justement nous avons demandé si les
livres sont ils un moyen de parler de
ces événements dramatiques
ce que nous avons c'est ce que nous vous
avons demandé regarder sur soi peut être
plus parlant que qui voyait télé je
pense que ces traumatismes peut-être
plus que des images chapelette - moins
forte
je crois pas non parce qu'un livre c'est
trop générale il faut adapter son
discours en fonction des interlocuteurs
quand l'arrière frontières les enfants
et de l'âge des enfants
je pense oui c'est une bonne idée parce
que les enfants posent des questions sur
les événements qui se sont produits et
livre pourrait être moins choquant que
ce qui a été diffusé à la télé des
parents principe louable leur expliquer
mais je penses cali bon ça
devrait pas être mal
moi je vois plutôt par dialogue mais
c'est à cause de mon ancien métier
d'enseignant le livre pourrait être un
très intéressant après je pense pas
qu'il est bon d'expliquer aux enfants de
jeune âge en tout cas ce qui s'est passé
les attentats
les enfants bien évidemment dû voir ou
entendre ce qui s'était passé donc une
explication pour à leur niveau d'une
manière simple c'est un peu aux parents
c'est un peu aux parents de l'extraire
de ce milieu là c'est pas un livre ne
servir à rien du tout à mon avis cette
source des sujets graves qui sont bien
expliquées et bon il faut il faut il
faut que ce soit un bon faut le bon
vecteur quoi une réaction justement
après ces témoignages en basse sur des
sujets aussi forts chacun voit midi à sa
porte 1 et chacun démarche qu'elle était
tellement vous avez publié ce texte
une autre marche est justement pour
répondre à ce que certains disaient lors
de ce petit reportage permettre aux
familles aux enfants aux écoles de
discuter et pour ça il faut un matériau
et c'est vrai que le livre qui prend une
certaine distance avec l'info à flot sur
les écrans peut permettre de prendre du
recul est dû discuter ensemble
il y a des photos qui ne vont pas du
tout être des photos choquantes bien
évidemment des strass ben oui alors si
vous voulez le livre il est constitué
d'un poème très beau et très fort d'un
très grand poète francophone originaire
du maroc qui s'appelle abdellatif un
très grand monsieur et il nous offre un
regard sur les événements qui dépasse
les événements et justement avec les
enfants il nous faut dépasser les
événements voir ce qu'il ya d'essentiel
ce qu'il ya autour aussi que ça occulte
pas tous ceux qui agissent pour la paix
pour la nature dans le pays sur la
planète il ya plein de choses positives
qui pourraient être occultés dans la
tête d'un gamin or on a fait venir au
monde pour grands
yvon toute liberté et pour se construire
pas pour l'inquiéter donc nos livres
sont là pour donner l'occasion aux
enfants aux familles de décrypter un
petit peu tout cela de prendre de la
distance et peut-être grâce au travail
des poètes des artistes de prendre un
petit peu d'air alors je voulais juste
amener une petite précision le livre
devait sortir pour l'anniversaire des
événements de charlie hebdo en janvier
effectivement mais nous allons réussir à
le sortir pour le prochain salon de
livre de montreuil c'est à dire la
semaine prochaine incluant toutes les
informations sur les événements qui
viennent de se passer c'est une prouesse
éditorial qu'une réussissant grâce à
notre équipe
arudy monde qui travaille à voisin de
bretagne comme vous le disiez grâce aux
imprimeurs et au relieur qui ont voulu
quand une des faits se mobiliser pour
que le livre soit prêt pour ce grand
rendez-vous annuel du livre jeunesse à
montreuil
c'était important que votre proposition
parce que je pense que deux maisons
d'édition à genève qui ont essayé de
sortir ce genre de livre aussi vite je
crois et c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens
nous attendent sur ce sujet parce que
c'est un petit peu la patte de la maison
aussi si on est parfois dans des comptes
dans l'imaginaire on est aussi très
souvent sur ce qui pose problème sur la
planète comme par exemple ce livre qu'on
vient de sortir aussi haut à propos de
mal à la belle figure donc prix nobel de
la paix qui se bat pour le droit des
filles à l'école et qui n'est pas sans
rapport avec qu'on vient de vivre
puisque c'est une jeune musulmane elle a
18 ans elle et pakistanaises
et elle a failli mourir sous les balles
des talibans elle se bat elle aussi
contre l'intégrisme
il se doit cela doit nous aider
injustement agir ensemble pour qu'ils
aient pas d' amalgame de fait dans le
pays et pour qu'on discerne bien les
choses on se bat contre des gens qui ont
commis ces crimes qui sont des
terroristes et qui sont loin d'être des
musulmans alors j'ai la chance de
parcourir c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un très beau livre à conseiller vraiment
aux enfants votre sur une actualité
c'est que vous participez justement donc
au sein du livre de presse jeunesse de
montreuil qui se déroule du 2 au 7
décembre ce livre sera proposé lui aussi
des nouveautés
bien sûr ce livre sera présent les
auteurs seront présents présente en
l'occurrence pour dédicacer leurs
ouvrages
donc le salon de montreuil c'est un
grand rendez vous pour échanger ensemble
pour rencontrer les créateurs
on se régale quand on va au salon
j'espère que les événements ont pas trop
dissuader les familles de venir nous
voir au salon c'est un très beau moment
et faire de ses propres gammes un des
enfants d'avoir deux livres c'est quand
même une nouvelle réussite dans son
éducation
vous montrez lettre ouverte à tous les
terriens
voilà c'est un livre qu'on l'a de prises
de paroles d'enfants justement qui nous
parle de tout ce qui fait leur vie leurs
rêves leur colère tout ce qui fait le
monde il y a des lettres très grave et
qui nous interpelle fortement sur la
violence subie par certains au sein de
leur famille par exemple meilleur aussi
des lettres pleines de fantaisie qui
nous font décoller on n'écoute pas assez
la parole des enfants envoyés sur la
question des événements qui viennent de
se dérouler on se pose beaucoup la
question comment on va le dire aux
enfants comment voile et produisent tout
cela on devrait aussi se demander qu'est
ce qu'ils ont à nous dire
dans ces moments là et est ce que eux
mêmes ne sont pas dépositaires d'une
parole un peu par essence d'une paroles
d'espoir justement qu'il peut nous faire
du bien nous aussi donc c'est un peu
dans cet esprit qu'on a donné la parole
à des centaines d'enfants et une petite
précision les droits d'auteur de ce
livre seront remis à l'unicef
ce qui boucle la boucle c'est est un
beau projet ce sont des projets
originaux délai par ses origines et qui
change en fait parce qu'on peut voir
chez les enfants parce que c'est
difficile pour une maison d'édition
comme la vôtre d'exister parmi les
grandes maisons d'édition plus on peut
le dire c'est qu'on essaie justement
c'est d'autant plus difficile
aujourd'hui que la crise est là et que
les familles au moins 2 de trésorerie je
dirais pour acheter des livres
donc on résiste
je crois fort bien ça va faire 20 ans
bientôt l'année prochaine que rue du
monde existe et je dois le dire je le
dire en face de quatre années d'une
personne très active dans le monde des
médiathèques ans résiste beaucoup grâce
aux enseignants et aux bibliothécaires
qui apprécie beaucoup notre travail qui
s'en servent bruit beaucoup et c'est
vrai que s'il n'y avait pas en france ce
magnifique réseau de la lecture publique
je crois que des petites maisons comme
la nôtre on aurait du mal à exister et
du coup ces livres-là du mal à naître
donc vous voyez labour est réglé entre
le dynamisme public et la vitalité de
du paysage éditorial dans le pays nous
on le ressent très fortement à du monde
c'est comme ça que du monde et n'est
d'ailleurs et bien ce sera justement
donc notre mot de la fin alors je le
rappelle j'atteste dont texte
d'abdellatif laâbi enrichi de textes
explications et d'illustrations
également sera publié donc avant le 7
janvier donc en 2015 dès la semaine
prochaine voilà vous savez c'est une
exclusivité vous serez présent du 2 au 7
décembre au salon du livre et de la
presse jeunesse à montreuil et je le
rappelle la fête du conte se poursuit
jusqu'au 5 décembre sur l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines merci à
vous d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
et aujourd'hui c'était la répétition
générale pour les élèves de cm1 et cm2
des écoles pagnol et bouvet de
coignières associé au théâtre alphonse
daudet ils ont monté un spectacle les
aventures de pinocchio dans le cadre de
leur thé appétant d'activités
périscolaires dernière répétition avant
la représentation en public samedi soir
sephora namani et jeremic et c'est d'un
lion assisté regarder
il
à chaque commune sont et ap la ville de
coignières s'est associé au théâtre
alphonse daudet pour créer un pôle
spectacles vivants répétition générale
aujourd'hui du spectacle les aventures
de pinocchio pour les enfants dtap en
compagnie des comédiens qui les
encadrent l'intérêt c'est que les
enfants voient les gens qui les forme
toute l'année qui les voit comment aussi
avec les mêmes difficultés et ça se
passe très très bien comme les
intervenants qu'ils ont toutes les
semaines vient il et il travaille avec
eux ils voient les qu'ils ont autant de
difficultés que pour ce pour se mettre
sur scène et se mettre dans l'histoire
les élèves de cm1 cm2 des écoles pagnol
et bouvet prépare depuis trois mois
chaque semaine leur spectacle les
aventures de pinocchio un spectacle
jeune public qui propose du chant de la
danse et du théâtre
la spontanéité et c'est ça qui est très
agréable là c'est que les gens les les
enfants sont très heureux ils sont comme
des poissons dans l'eau et il joue à
jouer leurs personnages et sache ça je
suis très très heureux de ça et moi je
sais que j'ai bien et on prend tous un
réel plaisir avec eux à partager ça
après la répétition générale
représentation en public prévues les
samedi 28 novembre et 5 décembre
et comme chaque jeudi c'est maintenant
une tradition la chronique sport avec
notre joyeuse et sportif bonsoir florane
du rugby pour débuter cette chronique
sport chez les seniors le squer rugby
deuxième de promotion d'honneur reçoit
ce dimanche à 15 heures le leader
clairement pour le choc de cette 7e
journée pour nous parler de cet
événement nous recevons sur ce plateau
va pas rien le coach des saint
quentinois bonsoir bon sens alors vous
restez sur une très belle victoire le
week-end dernier contre fontenaisienne
25 à 10 une cinquième victoire en cinq
matches est ce qu'on peut dire que vous
êtes prêts on est prêts on est lancé son
assaut de bonne dynamique en tout cas
parce qu'on est invaincu depuis le début
de la saison que sont épiés plus dans
l'équipe 2 donc ça montre qu'on a un
groupe étoffé qui répond présent
maintenant il ya un gros challenge qui
nous attend ce week-end et je pense
qu'on est pris pour attendre
clermont est ce que vous craignez cette
équipe c'est une équipe qui est forte
c'est un peu hâlé l'ogre aussi de cette
poule avec nous je pense qu'on est les
deux leaders de la poule
donc on est invaincus tout les tous les
deux donc ya une raison on est deux
équipes totalement différentes dans le
style de jeu mais il ya une grosse
confrontation qui se bat on se connaît
bien on a joué une dernière contre et
vous avez gagné les gars il y en avait
gagné les deux matchs donc en espérant
que cela même cette année et est-ce
qu'il faudra reproduire un petit peu le
jeu que vous produisez au quotidien
c'est à dire redoublements de passes
vitesse ou est-ce qu'il faudra peut-être
un peu modifié votre jeu par rapport à
ce match moi je rends les temples du
solide peut-être défensivement faut
garder notre force et ce mouvement
justement donc faut qu'on garde ça après
fonds s'est en effet appliqué sur sur le
jeu d'avants sur sur la défense qui vont
être des éléments super important pour
pouvoir répondre présent contre un club
de clermont qui est très organisé très
très costaud devant donc
donc oui et est ce que le classement
final de cette poule se joue ce week-end
selon le classement final n'ont appris
psychologiquement c'est vrai que c'est
important d'aujourd'hui marqué notre
notre empreinte vraiment sur la poule
montré que jusqu'à le rugby est présent
et prendre cette première place ça
serait peut-être un peu plus symbolique
mais c'est important pour nous et pour
pour la suite de la saison et est ce
qu'il ne faudra pas peut-être jouer le
match dans sa tête plusieurs fois parce
qu'on sait que c'est un match important
est ce que les joueurs devront justement
ne pas jouer le match on a dans leurs
têtes avant de le jouer sur le terrain
bah c'est vrai que c'est le risque c'est
que on se met la pression qu'on
réfléchisse trop au match
à vouloir trop bien faire à refaire le
match la nuit d'avant bon aujourd'hui on
est dans une dynamique où qui est
positive on a une équipe très jeune donc
ça peut être le piège mais je pense
qu'on vient sur le terrain pour prendre
du plaisir que les joueurs sont là pour
prendre du plaisir et du coup il faut
transformer ce peut-être cette pression
ce petit stress en quelque chose de
positif pour mettre encore plus
engagement sur le terrain
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
le match donc entre le sky rugby et
clermont est programmée ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade du bout des clous forum
et en titre maintenant le ballon ovale
pour le handball avec les féminines de
montils donc en nationale une féminine
les filles coachées par philippe
l'étrange joueront ce samedi à 20h30 à
domicile contre aulnay en match en
retard mais il montagne sont favorites
sur cette 7e journée les handballeuses
saint quentinois sont en forme elle
vient d'accrocher sur leur terrain
angoulême 32 à 32 un gros morceau de la
division
vous voulez parier sur un match ce
week-end florane vous pouvez mettre une
petite pièce sur les féminines de
montille me retenais écouter mes
conseils bien noté est nickel je prends
note j'écouterai vos conseils un dernier
rendez vous sport trap jouera ce
week-end pour tenter de reprendre la
deuxième place du classement
oui florane trap a perdu pour la
première fois de la saison le week-end
dernier contre vers 1 à 0 à l'extérieur
conséquence les trappistes sont
abandonnés la deuxième place du
classement au profit de saint leu pour
rebondir les saint quentinois reçoivent
plus tôt ce dimanche au stade gilbert
chance a qu une équipe qui compte le
même nombre de points que les yvelinois
l'objectif sur cette partie est donc
clair gagner pour creuser l'écart à
l'écart avec plus tôt et tenter de
reprendre la deuxième place du
championnat
merci michael on vous retrouve dans
quelques minutes il me semble pour votre
taux question d'ailleurs les sports nous
allons justement parler d'élimination de
versailles en coupe de france mais
également de voile avec le versailles et
tanguy de lamotte j'espère que vous à
regarder et vous allez regarder les
missions en régie francs lui évidemment
mais diane je ne raterais ça pour rien
au monde
merci à vous et la semaine prochaine on
vous retrouve pour la chronique mais
aussi lundi pour le 7-8 sport et une
dernières informations avant de refermer
ce journal ce soir à 19 heures 30 et
demain à 21h le prisme à elancourt
accueille la compagnie déclic théâtre
des comédiens amateurs et professionnels
sur scène pour un classique du
répertoire de william shakespeare le
songe d'une nuit d'été
six jeunes amateurs de trappes issus des
matchs d'impro participe en effet au
projet la pièce raconte l'histoire de
jeunes amours contrariées d'artisans
devenant comédien ne fait bien sûr si la
forme a évolué le fond lui ne change pas
il s'agit toujours une pièce autour du
désir et de son apprentissage et c'est
la fin de ce journal je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis alors restez avec nous
car vous savez vous avez rendez vous
avec à 19h30 avec michael almy d'euros
et ses chroniqueurs pour le talk
si on parlait sport demain vous
retrouvez wilfried est richy pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal quant
à moi je vous retrouve lundi
je vous souhaite donc une bonne soirée
et un excellent week end